le combat pour la république c'est aussi
un combat qui se mène à l'école et
aujourd'hui on peut se demander quelle
est la vision de la république quant à
jack vallaud belkacem confie à des
associations qui pensent que la laïcité
c'est une violence assimilationniste
quelle est sa vision de la république
quand aujourd'hui l'épreuve d'histoire
sont réduits à la portion congrue 40
pages en 2008 une seule page aujourd'hui
et avec les pages les plus sombres de
notre histoire où est la république
quand les programmes de liste de
littérature sont totalement passé sous
silence et qu'il n'y a plus un auteur
plus une oeuvre dans tout le programme
du collège où est la république quand on
sait aujourd'hui que l'ale l'illettrisme
est un fardeau pour notre pays
20% des jeunes maîtrisent pas la lecture
dans deux pays comme la floride
on a réussi à réduire sa en quatre ans
on a divisé l'illettrisme par dix et en
france par idéologie on refuse de mener
les bonnes réformes
donc aujourd'hui le combat pour la
république c'est le combat des
républicains nous devons être en
première ligne pour lutter contre la
réforme du collège et contre la réforme
des programmes scolaires